LUKE: Some of these have to
do with data quality.
Is that OK just to go ahead
and ask those now?
DANIEL: Yeah.
LUKE: OK.
Well, you said too short
description, you don't want to
tell us how short a too
short description is?
Is that right?
DANIEL: Maybe these guys can
address it better than I can,
but there's a suggested length
for the description.
I think it's 250 or maybe
500 characters.
And I think descriptions less
than that length will be
accepted sometimes, but
too short, it's not a
well defined notion.
It's something that our parser
and validation methods will
actually determine on their
own whether it's too short
not, whether you're doing a good
enough job describing it.
But again, I probably can't
speak to that as
well as these guys.
Do you guys have anything
to add?
CHRIS: I mean, I agree
with what you said.
I think too short description
is definitely a
recommendation.
You obviously don't want people
to-- the reason that
it's not a hard and fast rule is
that [UNINTELLIGIBLE] want
to encourage people to put stuff
in there that is not
actually relevant
to the product.
So it's really just a way to
say, hey, we believe that your
best descriptions, long
descriptions, are a benefit to
users when they're looking
at a product or
searching for a product.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the product is.
There is no specific hard and
fast line, where we'd say this
is too short and it's
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
It's more, again, just trying
to make the merchant
understand that the better
descriptions they give, the
better they can understand that
data and make it more
relevant to users.
LUKE: I'm just asking because
I want to validate, right.
So it's easy for me just to have
some sort of minimum and
I can just say, it's less than
250, that they need to supply
more information.
CHRIS: Yeah, so for that, I'd
say that's right what you just
said there.
Try to make it.
But again, we really don't
want just a bunch of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] data thrown
in just for the sake of
throwing in unnecessary data.
DANIEL: So if they can make
the 250, that's great.
If not, got to take it on
a case by case basis.
LUKE: OK.
Should I go to number two?
DANIEL: Sure, and
then we can--
LUKE: So, [? with is draft, ?]
I thought in the old days, if
you uploaded is draft true, it
would load a deactivated
product.
DANIEL: So this API--
maybe you're talking
about base API--
this API has only been around
since December of 2010.
So it's barely over
a year old.
I've only been on the team
since August of 2011.
I've never ever come across--
so is draft in the .net library
corresponds to the app
draft element from the
app XML namespace.
And that, as far as I know,
has never been a
part of this API.
So you can send it, we'll parse
it and return it, but we
don't do anything with it.
You want to use availability
for that.
And availability is actually one
of the required elements.
LUKE: Just so you know, it is
in the .net Client library.
So I can--
DANIEL: It is because when you
write software for so many
different things that share
namespaces and share different
utilities, we want to write as
little duplicate code as
possible, right.
So that's in one of the parent
classes, but it isn't
necessary for you to use.
There are some other things in
those parent classes that use
part of the app namespace or the
batch namespace, or parts
we just don't use
for this API.
LUKE: So if I load something
as available out of stock,
will it load deactivated, and
then it will not go to review
immediately?
DANIEL: I'm not 100%
sure on that.
Do you guys know,
Chris or Raf?
Does out of stock make
it deactivated?
CHRIS: I'm not 100%
sure either.
DANIEL: So I don't think out
of stock deactivates it.
If you set an expiration date
that's already occurred,
that'll deactivate it.
LUKE: Ah, thank you.
DANIEL: Obviously if you send a
delete, that will delete it.
But if you want to keep certain
things around like
ranking and stuff like that, I
don't know exactly how that
works but I do know
they're different.
I can get a more detailed
answer for you on that.
I'm not entirely sure what
out of stock does.
Let's hear the full details
of Andrew's question now.
So Andrew, the guys on my far
left, I don't know if they're
on your left, are Chris and Raf,
they're here with ops.
Chris deals mostly with data
quality and things of that
sort in the US, and
Raf is in EMEA.
So hopefully these guys will be
able to be on point and get
exactly what you need.
So let's hear it.
ANDREW: Hi.
Can you hear me?
Oh good.
Sorry, this is my first try
with this hangout thing.
The questions I have are about
best practices for
international sites, languages,
things like that.
We have--
Zazzle, which is the company I
work for, has sites around the
world and lots of different
levels of quality of content
for those sites.
So for example, we have
a lot of really good
English content in Canada.
We have some really good French
content in Canada.
I know that the shopping
API doesn't place any
limitations on what--
there's not an explicit
limitation on what languages
you can send to what countries,
but I'm wondering
if there's something in the back
end that stops that, or
if there's a best practices,
or should we not ever send
English to Japan.
What do you guys think
about all that?
CHRIS: So we do have rules
for each country on which
languages are supported.
So for Japan, it would
be Japanese.
We wouldn't have the English
language item in Japan.
ANDREW: That will just be
stopped by the API, or that
will get rejected,
or what's the--
CHRIS: I don't know if it will
stop it or reject it.
Daniel, I don't know--
DANIEL: I don't know off the top
of my head, but I can find
out for you.
CHRIS: But it may be something
that gets flagged during
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] some of
the content into the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] index it.
We're actually--
we're all focused on
this right now.
So in EMEA we are seeing people,
committees serving
through UK.
And we know that this is not
a great user experience if
you're out here searching
athletic shopping UK, you
probably don't want to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ANDREW: Well, I mean presumably
Google knows what
language you're interested in
when you're doing the search.
So as long as you set the right
language, it seems like
that would be OK.
Google would just filter it out
for the people who they
don't think speak German.
CHRIS: Yeah, so unfortunately,
it's not that sophisticated.
So if you target a specific
country like [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
it will show in that picture.
ANDREW: OK.
CHRIS: So what we're doing
now, is the focus is on
inventing [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
UK.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
look over something that's in
a language that is not in
English [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in the UK.
So when you're submitting the
content, you have the API, are
you actually supplying the
language that it is?
ANDREW: Yeah.
I mean, right now we're not.
That's why--
we specify the language, but
we're only sending one
language to each country, which
means that we miss out
on Canadian French and most
of our purchases in the
Netherlands, weirdly not
in Dutch, in English.
So it's unclear to me whether
I could provide a better
experience to people in NL by
submitting both some Dutch
products and some English
products, as long as I flag
them with the right language,
which is part of the content
for shopping API.
You have to specify
the language.
CHRIS: So I think there's
two things here.
It's my understanding, and
maybe [UNINTELLIGIBLE] or
Daniel or I can look into
this, but I have a
clue to make it.
You set the language
to English.
[INAUDIBLE]
You'll see that's not something
that should be
indexed or that's not something
returned for search queries
on that property.
And so it just wouldn't
appear.
And then if you're to set the
language to the [INAUDIBLE]
that language [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ANDREW: Right, right,
obviously.
CHRIS: So I'm not up to speed on
exactly what our plans are
for supporting multiple
languages
in different markets.
But as far as I know, we're not
currently [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
market right now.
For example, we're not even
launched in Canada.
So I'm imagining you're
submitting for product listing
ads in Canada.
ANDREW: Yeah and Google
Affiliate Network.
Actually there's another one
too, but they're all through
the same API.
CHRIS: So actually there it
starts to get a little bit
more complex when you take
apart the listing
ads into the questions.
So then it's also how they want
to display this and how
that is useful to them.
So it's possible if you were
to submit to country Canada
language French, that even
a product search
wouldn't show it.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
would not launch there.
But it's possible
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
And whether the affiliate
network might be a little bit
useful for that.
So that's also [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
follow up on.
If they have any use
for content that's
submitted that way.
ANDREW: OK.
Well that's--
CHRIS: Does that make sense?
ANDREW: Yeah.
I didn't realize you guys hadn't
started to surface
things by language from
Google product.
I kind of went on Google and I
worked with one of our Dutch
speakers and we did some
searches in English and the
stuff came back in English, and
we did some searches in
Dutch and it came
back in Dutch.
And I was like, sweet,
that's Google.
But I guess it's a little bit
different for products.
CHRIS: It's a little
different.
And so our first focus is just
getting the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
language experience correct.
Then we're going to see it
make sense too, to have
additional languages supported
for each [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ANDREW: I think that probably
answers my question.
I actually had a question to
follow up the question that
was previously asked by--
I'm sorry I didn't catch
the name-- the previous
questioner.
Daniel mentioned that if you
delete the product it clears
it out of the system, including
ratings and things.
Is that--
DANIEL: So I'm not 100%
how that works.
But I think in many cases, if
you like to deactivate a
product but you know it's coming
back, it can be more
beneficial for you to set the
expiration date to a date
that's already passed or
deactivate it in that fashion.
Rather than to explicitly
delete the product.
But--
ANDREW: Yeah, it's unclear if
I can tell if it's going to
come back or not.
It's like some stuff becomes
unpopular and then becomes
popular again.
And some stuff becomes--
We usually just do deletes which
helps us keep under the
quotas and things like that.
But I was worried that maybe
the Christmas stuff, which
probably gets deleted in the
middle of the year because
nobody is looking at it,
nobody's buying it, does that
stuff then--
DANIEL: So once an item is
deactivated, it gets purged
eventually, but there's no
guarantees on how quickly or
how slowly that purging
will take.
So I imagine if you deactivated
it in May, by
November it's gone.
But I'm not 100%--
ANDREW: I was more--
So I guess that kind of
answers my question.
I was just hoping that maybe
Google was keeping around
like, this is a good product,
or people click on this
product, or something.
And then when it comes back
with the same ID later,
they're like, sweet, let's
put it back up.
DANIEL: First, I don't know if
that's true, and second, I
don't think I could comment
on it if I did know.
ANDREW: OK.
Well I mean, we could
do an experiment.
I understand that
you're launching
statistics on products.
Have you been able to
get those back?
I guess I could delete a
product and look at the
statistics get deleted after
a few days when I put the
product back in.
DANIEL: I'm not sure if you're
talking about the performance,
or if you're talking
about data quality.
That's been launched--
I don't know several months,
eight, nine months.
ANDREW: For some reason I always
get zeros whenever I
ask for it, even when they show
numbers on the UI, which
is sort strange.
DANIEL: That sounds
like a bug.
ANDREW: OK, I'll try it again.
DANIEL: No, like a
bug on our part.
If you encounter it again,
let me know.
Post to the forum or do on the
co.google.com/p/shoppingapis
list. And report it because
they should be the same.
But I guess that would
be an experiment
that may reveal something.
ANDREW: OK cool.
I'll mute myself so
I don't echo now.
DANIEL: Cool.
I would reiterate that if the
does come back, to continue to
use the same offer
ID for the item.
DANIEL: Yeah, for sure.
So Luke, you said you had
some more questions.
LUKE: Yeah, I'll follow up
on what he just said.
With regard to the performance
data, I didn't get impressions
information in those
data points.
OK, that's coming?
DANIEL: I don't know
that it's coming.
I haven't brought it up
with the team yet.
It doesn't seem like it'd
be too difficult to do.
But I wasn't around when the
original feature was launched,
I don't know why it's not
included, because clicks and
impressions sort of
go side by side.
That's on my to-do list of
something to follow up with.
I agree with you that that's
good data to have but I don't
know how available it is or how
easy it is to implement.
LUKE: Sale price and sale price
effective date, they're
not in the .net client
library, at
least not version 1.9.
DANIEL: Sounds like a bug.
LUKE: Oh really?
DANIEL: I will get
those in there.
Yeah, that one--
the guy who was on the content
API before me didn't do C
sharp.net and didn't really
ever touch it.
He just kind of asked for help
from other people who didn't
know the content API.
And I was the same-- didn't know
C sharp, didn't know .net
but I've started to actually
look at the library and try to
understand some stuff.
It's a little different
situation but every once in
awhile, I'll come across an
attribute that isn't in there
that should be.
And that's just some sort of
oversight from somebody less
familiar with the API itself.
But I will get those in
there if they're not.
And I assume, if I get them in
the library and there's no
release, you can build
everything locally, right?
You're good doing that?
With something this complex and
this big, we're not just
going to do a release for
15 lines of code.
All right, that's good.
Sounds like that was the last
two questions you had.
John, do you have
any questions?
JOHN: No.
No direct questions.
I can include one.
It's really about the
exception process.
We host many shops, and some of
our shops don't have brands
and the mandatory fields,
the unique IDs.
And then, I know that the
customer services have to do a
manual exception process.
It would be good if we had an
API to do that so we can
automate it.
So I guess I just need to put in
a change request, I guess,
or a feature request.
DANIEL: Whose customer
service?
Our customer service has--
JOHN: No, our company's
customer service.
DANIEL: OK.
JOHN: So what happens is
that we host shops.
A shop will register.
They won't put the unique
IDs in, so we
don't upload any products.
Instead, we give them alerts.
That say we can't upload
these, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ID.
They come back to say, we make
artificial flowers, or we make
this, we make that.
We then apply for an
exemption manually.
And we manually then
upload-- sorry--
we then set a flag and the
product's uploaded.
Well, customer services would
like all that automated.
I guess I need put that in
as a feature request.
DANIEL: Yeah if you want to
email me or ping the forum, or
I guess just put it right on
shopping API's issues list,
especially the form where you're
actually filing for the
exemptions would be helpful.
Because I'm not 100%
familiar with that
process since it is--
JOHN: Sure.
I'm not familiar with the
process, the customer will
deal with that.
But I know that at the regular
meetings they bring it out
that they spend a lot
of time doing this.
What I want to try to is make
sure that no data is uploaded
by the API unless it's valid and
contains all the necessary
managing fields.
So we actually stop
it at that point.
Alright, Daniel.
Anyway, thanks very much.
DANIEL: Sure.
CHRIS: In terms of the process
that is-- that's a relatively
good understanding of the
process so if the content is
in the unique identifiers,
we would flag that.
And then there is an exemption
process in which
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] could say,
oh yeah, we sell hand-made
flowers or artificial flowers,
and then our team reviews the
content and it exempts the
account from [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
unique identifiers, if
that's the case.
DANIEL: So you mean a unique
identifier like a G10.
CHRIS: Yeah.
DANIEL: OK.
I'm going to ping you off this,
with a question that I
don't know if is appropriate.
But--
JOHN: Yeah.
Their exactly the filter you
look for, they've got to have
a G10, they've got
to have a brand.
I think that's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
fields, OK, that they've got to
have. And we make sure that
our shops have completed
those.
And if they haven't, then we
stop the product from being
uploaded, and make sure those
fields have been filled in.
DANIEL: And Chris, do you know
is there a way to include like
handmade or something like that,
in the G10, or is that
something that really, it just
has to go through this formal
process currently.
CHRIS: So there is another
way to do that.
We're looking at--
so our team is sort of looking
at this and seeing how we can
make it more efficient.
We don't have the ability to
say, oh these are custom
products so you don't need to
flag these at this point.
DANIEL: Right.
And I'm sure, John, there's some
level of human validation
that's going on that it may be
hard to take away from the
process because of things like
spam and such that may want to
circumvent the review process
programmatically.
But I don't know off
the top of my head.
It's certainly a
complex issue.
JOHN: Certainly.
I'm not expecting an
instant response.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
imagine would work, is we'd
say, we apply for an
extension, and a couple of
days later after you've
validated the sites, and done
all your checks, you would
then come back and maybe we'd
get some sort of automated
request back.
So, I'm not suggesting an
instantaneous exemption
process, I'm more saying taking
the manual process out,
because that becomes kind of
almost zero touch, kind of.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], can I ask
you a quick question about
G10, and about validation?
In the moment we kind of just
passed that through.
Have you got any recommendations
on any vetting
that we should apply?
I know G10 is so open-ended.
Because obviously what I'm keen
to do is try and validate
data before we upload it.
DANIEL: Sure.
I have no clue.
So I will defer to
Chris and Raf.
CHRIS: I don't have anything
specific right now.
I actually would need to
review all the G10
requirements.
It's not something I've
looked at recently.
DANIEL: Do you know if there
are external services, or
places even within Google,
where we have
some official listing--
some sort of thing that you
could check against to do
vetting, like John says.
CHRIS: Is there specific
attributes or specific values
that you are interested
in knowing?
I think brand, we don't
have anything.
UPC I think, there's a
simple digit check.
Is there a right amount
of digits?
And then we do the
check digit--
like I forget exactly how it
works-- but when you add these
numbers does the last
digit, do they all
add up to the last--
It's called Check Digit.
I would need to look into it.
But we do that sort
of checking.
But not all UPCs actually--
DANIEL: Fall into that.
Yeah.
CHRIS: So beyond that, I don't
know if there's anything more
that you could do.
I mean, I think UPC is the
easiest one to sort of
validate that it's at least
in the correct format.
The method we do, really
internally, it's not something
we can do during processing,
the initial [? fee ?]
processing.
We do it much more internally.
Once we get the data, we start
to sort of sift over it and
understand what these
products are.
And that's when we start to do
some additional validation on
unique identifiers.
And that's really hard
for you to do.
DANIEL: Through the API, yeah.
JOHN: Thanks very much.
DANIEL: Sure.
So does anybody else
have questions?
Well, Danny, I wanted to ask
about the multi-client
account, and some business
information and customer
service information
through the app.
Is that something that is coming
up, like in the future?
DANIEL: That's another one of
those that I need to talk to
the team about.
There are definitely
gaps there that I
think should be fixed.
But I don't know what the
resources are to get them
fixed or how difficult it
would be to fix them.
But I will certainly
drive that forward.
Because I went through the
process on the merchants in
our UI, and it does seem sort
of counterintuitive that you
wouldn't be able to do that
through the API as well.
LUKE: Yeah.
I like the idea of my own
customers being able to-- it's
completely automated on
my side when their
account is set up.
Well I could also set up there
sub-account automatically, if
I could just kind of fill
that information in.
And then of course, the shipping
and tax, I'm going to
have to contact them on.
Cause we're going to have to
look at their Google checkout
account and then make sure
those two sets match.
But at least that block
would be cool to add.
DANIEL: Yeah, for sure.
And that's another big request,
has been setting
account level, tax, and shipping
through the API which
currently isn't available
either.
And it's something we may
get done this quarter.
This last quarter we had, I
think, three or four launches.
So, like maintenance
requests like these
were sort of secondary.
And this quarter I don't know
that we're going to have as
many launches.
I don't know if you guys have
gotten to use any of those
features from last quarter,
but there's a pretty cool
feature, the API dashboard,
within the merchant center,
that'll actually show you every
type of error you have,
the number of occurrences of
that error, and then also
it'll give you examples.
Example request and the
example response
error return to it.
It's really neat if you--
ANDREW: I love that feature.
DANIEL: Awesome.
It's great to hear we have
some happy users.
It's actually getting better.
I don't know when it's
launching, but we're writing
up a blog post--
or we're writing up some more
documentation about it, but
you'll actually be able to
replay requests from the
merchant center.
So you can change a little bit
of text, run it in dry run
mode, and see if it works.
So you can actually--
maybe not as relevant to you
Andrew, since you're super
technical-- but for some other
people are still fudging
around trying to make requests
work, they can actually change
requests in the merchant center
UI, and fiddle around
until they can actually
make them work.
It's going to be super neat.
ANDREW: We had a character
encoding issue that was caused
by some data that got changed
in the database.
And I was like, I don't know,
I didn't do anything.
What happened?
But the API dashboard was just
like, this is what's wrong.
DANIEL: That's awesome.
ANDREW: And I was so excited.
DANIEL: Yeah, for sure.
That's awesome.
But anyway Luke, not to derail
from your question too much,
I'm certainly going to be
pushing these through.
And it'll probably be in the
next week or two once I get
these developer guys launched.
I know that's something you
want as well, the feature
parody with the other languages
and being able to do
everything you want to
with the .net library
and things like that.
And it's something I'm
concentrating on with most of
my time right now.
But I will--
LUKE: I'm glad to hear that
Google is pro-Microsoft.
DANIEL: Well, no it's
pro-developer.
And there's a strong .net
community, so that's my job,
right, make you happy.
C# isn't so bad, I guess.
I'm a Python guy, and I miss
private variables and I miss
functions with more
than one signature
and things like that.
LUKE: It's so easy
in our languages,
you know what I mean?
DANIEL: I prefer duck typing
still, but that's me.
But it's refreshing every
once in awhile.
Compiled languages--
computers are pretty powerful
these days.
I don't know how long compiled
languages will be around.
Probably for awhile,
given the--
JOHN: You have to order
a raspberry pi.
DANIEL: What's that?
JOHN: You have to order
a raspberry pi.
DANIEL: Why's that?
JOHN: Have you heard of
the raspberry pi?
DANIEL: No, is it
a python joke?
JOHN: No, it's a $20 computer.
JOHN: And the [? python ?],
it runs Linux.
They're aiming it for
educational tool, and they're
pushing Python.
So you need to order
your raspberry pi.
DANIEL: For $20 why not?
JOHN: Just Google it.
Google raspberry pi.
DANIEL: OK.
I'll Google it.
JOHN: That's p-i, by the way,
as opposed to p-i-e.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Daniel, can I just
say actually, a
really bit of good feedback.
Actually the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
several months, OK.
And it's working beautifully.
Every day, it sends up its
updates and things, and it
just works.
So I know, through the forums,
there is lots of people
questioning things and
challenging you with difficult
questions and everything,
but we found the
interface works great.
DANIEL: That's awesome.
Thanks for the feedback.
Yeah, we try to make sure
there's uptime all the time
across all Google services.
And I think it is pretty
refreshing, especially given
some of the more fledgling
services, some of the issues
you can have.
So Luke, if you do have specific
questions on use of
the client library,
let me know.
I'll make an announcement
tomorrow or
maybe even later today.
We'll do another one exactly
two weeks from today.
So April 32, aka May 2.
And I guess I'll see
you guys then.
It will be at 10 Eastern, which
what's the UK is plus
eight, I believe.
So that is--
10 Pacific.
Oh I'm so sorry.
Yes it will be at 10 Pacific,
which I believe is 6:00 PM in
the UK, yeah John?
JOHN: Yeah, that's correct.
It's 6:36 in the UK
at the moment.
DANIEL: Great.
Cool.
So thanks everyone.
Thanks especially to Chris
and Raf for showing up.
And we'll try to get back and
post to the forum with the
questions that we couldn't
answer to your satisfaction.
All right?
See you guys.
Thanks.
Bye.